you know I'm not sure where people are
getting that nobody's talking about the
train derailment everywhere I look I see
stories about the train derailment local
media National media New York Times and
Washington Post CNN and Fox News
Independent Media Twitter Reddit
everywhere I look people are talking
about the train derailment so for the
people emailing me saying David why is
no one talking about it I see everyone
talking about it and one of the things
that we are learning as that talking
continues is that the train derailment
story is quickly building and building
pointing more and more in the direction
of sadly being a story about regulation
and I know that the right hates this the
right wants to argue
that businesses have a an incentive to
regulate themselves why wouldn't they
right I mean because if they don't
regulate themselves and something bad
happens then it's terrible for PR except
a lot of these companies don't really
depend on PR in the sense of uh uh
consumer-facing businesses so it doesn't
really apply and we know from endless
examples from history that it simply
doesn't work that way we have an article
here
um from Freight waves which covers the
um train industry I guess we would say
Norfolk Southern eliminated key
maintenance role in the derailment
region per the union there used to be
something called maintenance and if you
read the article you learn a lot about
what is going on in the world of trains
One Union rail One Union of rail workers
is questioned declining maintenance
standards following the derailment
a device that can play a role in
preventing derailments is the Wayside
HotBox detector it uses infrared sensors
to detect bearings axles or other
components that are overheating and then
it uses radio signals to flag rail Crews
of any overheated components the rail
car that initiated the derailment we now
know had an overheated wheel bearing
according to a report from the NTSB
Wayside HotBox detectors are usually
placed every 25 miles along a railroad
their use has contributed to a 59
percent decrease in train accidents
caused by axle and bearing related
factors since 1990. declining headcounts
have led to these mechanisms receiving
less preventative maintenance according
to an official from the Brotherhood of
Railroad signalmen Union the fra has no
regulations requiring the use or
maintenance of HotBox detectors a hotbox
detector in East Palestine notified the
crew moments before the Train derailed
it's unclear if any HotBox detector
prior to East Palestine notified Crews a
surveillance video shared on Facebook
from an Indus industrial facility in
Salem Ohio 20 miles from East Palestine
suggests the Train's axle was already on
fire
so there are a lot of components to this
and I have friends in the railroad
industry and I've been talking to them
all about this and we are not yet at the
point where we can definitively say the
problem was not enough of these Hot Box
detectors
and part of the reason why there weren't
enough is that there is no minimum
requirement for where they have to be
there are recommendations but not a
typically they are every 25 miles but
there is no actual requirement so one
possible explanation here and again
we're all trying to learn about what
happened one possible explanation here
is
surveillance video showed that there
already appeared to be a fire on the
train 20 miles away 20 miles away
from where it eventually derailed and if
indeed there was no hot box detector
there even though the recommendation is
that there should have been that is an
argument that were were it a requirement
to have those hot box detectors they
might have been notified about this fire
which eventually led to the derailment
as many as 20 miles earlier at which
point you could have stopped the Train
the fire would not have been nearly as
big and you could have conceivably
prevented the derailment altogether so
that would be an example of how there is
under regulation there's the
recommendation of where to place the
HotBox detectors but there is not the
requirement
so it's a chain of decisions and things
that take place with regulation coming
down from the top now we also know that
more generally there's another issue
here which is Norfolk Southern wants to
make as much money as they can and we
have reports that Norfolk Southern Cut
workers cut maintenance and opted not to
do
as much in terms of expenditures on new
Safety Systems when they didn't have to
all of that in order to save on expenses
and to make more money and then the
third element of this of course and I
told you this last week or the week
before there were additional
requirements placed on trains by the
Obama Administration which were repealed
under the Trump Administration in 2018.
I'm not going to redo that story now
because we all I already told you the
details of that Obama putting in place
these things and the Trump
Administration rolling them back
so we are still building up our exact
understanding of what took place here
but it is increasingly pointing to a
story about under regulation where we
know the technology that can prevent
these things we know that when the
technology is used these events
decreased dramatically and that was not
in place in this particular case we will
soon know for sure whether that was the
cause but the early report says it was
so remember when the right says we're
over regulated everywhere there may be
over regulation in some places and I'm
certainly open to we should have a
reason for regulations that are put in
place but removing regulations for the
sake of saying we've removed regulations
not only doesn't make any sense it also
is extraordinarily dangerous when you're
looking at situations like this we will
have links to all of these stories I've
been putting up on the screen in the
description to the YouTube videos for
these stories you can find find the
YouTube channel at youtube.com the David
Pacman show